un mouvement hip hop peut se faire dans
une autre danse mais en fait pour moi
c'est une histoire d'énergie
j'adore ce qu'elle invente façon en fait
honte elle met en avant les individus
marion quand même c'est quelqu'un quoi
quand on arrive là on en a déjà entendu
parler pour moi ça devrait pas tu as
c'est plus le côté street est très
bientôt pour la rencontre classique hip
hop c'était d'aller vers quelque chose
de plus hybride que d'aller vers quelque
chose de classique qui fait d'huile
pense que marié aujourd'hui elle
représente très bien la manière dont
j'avais envie de garder cette espèce
d'énergie bestial qu'on a dans le hip
hop un peu sauvage c'est très facile
succès musical est obligé de faire
quelque chose de très cadré tout en
s'amusant et en étant dans ton jeu dans
ton personnage et ses chorégraphies
senti qu'on me donne envie de danser
surtout dans sa quête est primordial
[Musique]
oh
ah ah
c'est sûr d'un type cas dans la danse
depuis qu'il est tout petit
son truc à lui c'est le hip hop sa mère
elle c'était la danse classique pour lui
scénariste sera t il a terriblement peur
de me ressembler sauf qu'ils se trompent
je vois ce que tu sais faire
je m'installe sur paris tout est là pour
longtemps
juste le temps de passer le concours
d'ici là faut vraiment y trouve un
boulot
jabil j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
vos nouveaux professeurs on n'a pas de
comptes amour entre c'est à nous de
décider qui donne de quoi tout est dans
le style et a pas de règle parce que le
hip hop ça vient des tripes
j'en pense j'ai tout essayé j'ai ce
guide et je leur ai montré ça marche pas
civile comme prof fais-toi confiance est
ce que ça vous tenterait de participer à
un concours de hip hop
aux mythes sont hostiles
un hip hop est un classique on va finir
par radio
radio avec accueil elle m'a beaucoup
parlé dit ouais elle m'a pas dit que
vous étiez 6004 nous c'est le concours
pour entrer à l'école de l'opéra genres
entre jours et alors là quand avait 8
ans tu as de quoi là maintenant
que tu te rends toi conte peuvent pas
gagner le concours sans toi je me bats
ma part depuis sa fille alors qu'elle
habitait dans tout à donner le doute a
toujours été mon pire ennemi
la peur de pas être à la hauteur
quand je te vois danser quand je danse
avec toi je vibre
même si t'es pas là
je pense avec toi
[Musique]